[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem mittwoch die vom sport hat
norbert lehmann
wir beginnen mit einer nachricht die
viele freuen dürfte
mit stufenplan zurück zu mehr freiheit
bund und länder beschließen bis zum 20
märz die korona maßnahmen schrittweise
zu lockern
abzug oder aufmarsch anders als russland
sieht die nato noch keine anzeichen von
deeskalation an der ukrainischen bank
und der medaillenregen geht weiter die
deutschen langläuferinnen katharina
heinig und victoria kam polen
überraschend olympia gold im teamsprint
das ende der korona beschränkungen hat
die schweiz verzichtet ab morgen auf
fast alle maßnahmen österreich ab
fünften märz und auch für deutschland
haben bund und länder heute lockerungen
beschlossen verbunden mit dem appell
vorsichtig zu bleiben in einem ersten
schritt dürfen sich geimpfte und
genesene privat ohne einschränkungen
treffen zudem entfallen die kontrollen
im einzelhandel zugang haben alle
allerdings weiter nur mit maske im
zweiten schritt dürfen ab dem vierten
märz wieder mehr zuschauer zu
großveranstaltungen und neben geimpften
und genesenen können auch getestete
wieder in gastronomie und hotels ab dem
20 märz sollen dann alle tiefer
greifenden schutzmaßnahmen entfallen
etwa auch die home office pflicht
weniger berichtet
deshalb nicht so lange gedauert heute
von beschlussentwurf zur
beschlussentwurf hatte sich die letzten
tagen abgezeichnet dass am 20 märz die
allermeisten maßnahmen bundesweit fallen
sollen
wir haben
zwei jahren auch mal
verdient dass es irgendwie wieder besser
wird und es sieht ein bisschen danach
aus dass wir genau das auch vor uns
haben wir dürfen bei all dem optimismus
und der zuversichtlich wir verzeichnen
nicht unvorsichtig werden deshalb muss
man auch klar sagen die pandemie ist
eben noch nicht vorbei wir müssen
achtsam bleiben weil gerade besonders
schutzbedürftige personen gruppen von
schweren verläufen betroffen sind und
auch in zukunft betroffen sein können
wir müssen achtsam bleiben weil in
teilen deutschlands die ältere
bevölkerung nicht über einen so hohen
impfschutz verfügt wie in anderen
ländern
von einem tag der freiheit einem freedom
day wie es aus teilen der fdp erklingt
wird oder falls nicht reden ich halte
von solchen begriff nicht sie werden dem
ernst der lage nicht angemessen und
deshalb ist es auch kein
eine formulierung mit der die parteien
der regierung zb umlaufen
uneinigkeit in der regierung gibt es
auch bei einer weiteren forderung der
länder sie wollen basisschutz maßnahmen
die sie im notfall auch über den
zwanzigsten märz hinaus ergreifen können
wenn sie rasch und vor besonnen handeln
wollen brauchen sie irgendeinen werkzeug
dazu und je mehr sie hörten aufbauen um
so ein werkzeug in die hand nehmen zu
können dessen später wird's was dabei
geht es unter anderem um die frage nach
einer masken pflicht auch um die
impfpflicht wird weiter gerungen die
meisten maßnahmen aber werden nun bis
märz geschichte
ja noch ist die pandemie nicht vorbei
schon unter ben ali in berlin es soll
einen basisschutz geben was heißt das ja
das kann man noch nicht genau sagen nach
diesem beschluss der momentan ist es nur
eine wunschliste der länder die da drin
steht die möchten auch nach dem
zwanzigsten märz mindestens die
möglichkeit haben zum beispiel mit aha
regeln also dem tragen von masken in
bussen und bahnen oder geschlossenen
räumen mit publikumsverkehr gegen
mögliche lokale oder regionale corona
ausbrüche gegenzuhalten
aber auch mit einer weiteren test
pflicht oder auch mit der pflicht zum
impfnachweis also mit diesen berühmten
instrumentenkasten den sie gerne für den
fall der fälle zur verfügung hätten
allein sie entscheiden nicht darüber
diese hoheit liegt beim bundestag und
das wären jetzt die nächsten schritte
dass die bundesregierung das im
schutzgesetz entsprechend
infektionsschutzgesetz sozusagen
entsprechend anpassen müsste und dann
der bundestag darüber abstimmen müsste
und als mögliche hürde gilt hier die fdp
die ja die grenzen für regeln eher eng
setzen möchte da wird olaf scholz wenn
er den bundesländern entgegenkommen
möchte mit seinem koalitionspartner ins
gespräch gehen müssen und das möglichst
zügig damit das ganze noch rechtzeitig
vor dem auslaufen der maßnahmen am 20
märz im bundestag entschieden werden
kann dankeschön für diese information
aus berlin konterte partie war das mitte
januar hatte das robert-koch-institut
entschieden den genesenen status quasi
über nacht zu verkürzen von sechs auf
drei monate
das stieß auf kritik vor allem von der
fdp und der opposition jetzt stellte
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
klar über solch tiefgreifende
entscheidungen wie etwa den genesenen
status möchte er künftig selbst
entscheiden zu den öffnungszeiten gibt
es auch ein zdf spezial direkt im
anschluss an diese sendung und in der
zdf- heute erklären wir warum die
inzidenz womöglich nicht mehr das ganze
ausmass der pandemie zeigt
anderes großes thema heute zieht
russland wirklich einen teil seiner
truppen von der grenze zur ukraine ab
darüber diskutiert die welt nach den
ankündigungen aus moskau us präsident
biden ist sehr skeptisch und die nato
spitze glaubt sogar dass russland an
anderer stelle seinen aufmarsch
fortsetzt auch darüber beraten die nato
verteidigungsminister heute in brüssel
florian neumann fasst zusammen die
brücke ist hell erleuchtet kameras des
russischen verteidigungsministeriums in
bester position
man will dem westen ein bild zeigen wie
russland militärisches gerät von der
krim abzieht nur dass der westen diese
botschaft noch nicht so recht glaubt
nato
verteidigungsministertreffen in brüssel
wo die skepsis eindeutig überwiegt
wir freuen uns darauf beweise zu sehen
für einen russischen truppenabzug aber
wir müssen uns weiter auf alle
möglichkeiten vorbereitet
was wir auf den boden sehen ist kein
rückzug von truppen oder gerät wir sehen
nur wie russische truppen in position
gehen und wir haben eine cyber attacke
auf die ukraine gesehen
rückzug oder angriff während russland am
mittag weitere bilder von vermeintlich
abziehende militär veröffentlicht
rätselt der westen weiter und die nato
reagiert vorsorglich mit mehr soldaten
an ihrer ostflanke seit 2017 hat sie
dort im rahmen der verstärkten vorne
präsenz kampfgruppen in estland lettland
litauen und in polen stationiert jetzt
denkt man über ähnliche truppen in
rumänien nach möglicherweise auch in
ungarn bulgarien und der slowakei doch
endgültig entscheiden will auch die
deutsche verteidigungsministerium im
sommer
sollten wir nicht in dieser aktuellen
situation und vor dem hintergrund der
aktuellen situation machen sondern nach
einer intensiven prüfung und unter
beobachtung der situation dann erst mal
beobachten alle die situation in der
ukraine wo sie heute im stadion von kiew
flagge zeigen gegen den krieg und wo
mancher vielleicht ahnt dass diese
bedrohung sie vielleicht noch lange
begleiten könnte
wichtige entscheidung vom europäischen
gerichtshof die eu darf ihren
mitgliedern gelder kürzen wenn diese
gegen rechtsstaatliche prinzipien
verstoßen polen und ungarn hatten gegen
diesen sogenannten rechtsstaats
mechanismus geklagt ohne erfolg jetzt
müssen sie mit finanziellen sanktionen
rechnen
theoretisch jedenfalls eine geliehene k
details das winzerdorf mit 200 kilometer
nordöstlich von budapest ist eines der
reichsten von ungarn fast an jedem haus
prangt ein schild das eu fördergelder
ausweist ein ex geheimdienstchef und ein
jugendfreund von premierminister orban
haben hier ihr domizil um zu beweisen
dass korruption im spiel sein könnte
bräuchte man eine unabhängige justiz
aber auch die bringt orban zunehmend
unter seine kontrolle
das urteil des europäischen gerichtshofs
ist überdeutlich die eu darf künftig
mitgliedstaaten gelder kürzen wenn diese
durch die aushöhlung des rechtsstaats
nicht vor missbrauch geschützt sind eine
ohrfeige für ungarn und polen die
dagegen geklagt hatten der polnische
justizminister schäumt mechanischen
betrugsversuch unter dem vorwand der
rechtsstaatlichkeit wird immer mehr
macht aus souveränen mitgliedstaaten ins
hauptquartier nach brüssel verlagert
dort versuchen einflussreiche länder die
richtung der eu zu bestimmen in erster
linie berlin
das instrument hat die eu kommission
also jetzt doch seine anwendung bleibt
schwierig
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
scheut bislang den offenen streit mit
polen und ungarn der rechtsstaat in
europa brennt und jeder tag der da
weiter vergeht er ist ein tag zu viel
und deswegen muss die europäische
kommission jetzt schnell handeln
es gehe auch um die rechte von bürgern
in ganz europa argumentiert das
parlament die eu kommission kann also
künftig gelder für rechtsstaat sünder
zurückhalten wird sie es auch tun von
der leyen zögert denn sie fürchtet dass
polen und ungarn die eu auf anderen
politikfeldern die beim klimaschutz
blockieren könnten das urteil über den
rechtsstaats mechanismus ist gefallen
seine umsetzung aber wird weiter für
streit sorgen
unter großer anteilnahme wurde das
zweite opfer des polizistenmordes
beigesetzt in ihrem heimatort im
saarland gedachten hunderte kollegen
jasmin b mit eine ehrenwache die
24-jährige und ihr kollege waren ende
januar bei kusel in rheinland pfalz bei
einer fahrzeugkontrolle erschossen
worden im landtag in mainz erhoben sich
die abgeordneten zu einer schweigeminute
und jetzt zu einem prozess in frankfurt
am main vor gericht steht ein
54-jähriger der wüste drohschreiben
verfasst haben soll an anwältinnen
moderatorinnen politikerinnen
unterschrieben mit heil hitler und nsu
2.0 die staatsanwaltschaft hält den
berliner für einen einzeltäter viele
betroffene glauben dagegen dass aus
polizeikreisen gezielt daten an ihn
weitergegeben wurden in kind klinge
berichtet eine klare geste des
angeklagten alexander m soll
beleidigungen und todesdrohungen
verschickt haben unterzeichnet mit nsu
2.0 gingen die insgesamt 116
drohschreiben vor allem an frauen die in
der öffentlichkeit stehen wie die
anwältin seema wildes oder die
linken-politikerin janine wissler die
anklage wirft dem angeklagten insgesamt
allein 67 fälle von beleidigung vor es
geht aber auch noch weitere delikte
nämlich bedrohungen
volksverhetzung dann auch noch besitz
von kinderpornografischem material
verstoß gegen das waffengesetz weil
persönliche daten der betroffenen von
computern der polizei unter anderem in
frankfurt abgerufen worden waren stand
die polizei selbst lange im fokus der
ermittlungen es wurden rechte chat
gruppe nennt der einen zusammenhang mit
dem drohschreiben soll es aber nicht
gegeben haben viele der opfer zweifeln
dass an es wurden zielgerichtet
informationen über mich und meine
familie insbesondere beim eine
zweijährige damals zweijährige tochter
abgerufen die dann 90 minuten später
in einem droh faxe
einflossen die staatsanwaltschaft geht
davon aus dass sich der 54 jährige
arbeitslose it techniker aus berlin die
daten der adressaten erschlichen hat
indem er sich am telefon als polizei
kollege auswies der prozess wird das
natürlich in den nächsten tagen daneben
auch noch genauestens noch genauestens
herauskehren aber bisher ist kein
verdacht kein anfangsverdacht da das
eine mittäterschaft von einem
polizeibeamten der hessischen polizei
gegeben ist der angeklagte will morgen
aussagen ein urteil wird frühestens ende
april erwartet
ungemütlich bis gefährlich so wird das
wetter in deutschland ab heute nacht in
nordrhein-westfalen und brandenburg
fällt morgen die schule aus rheinland
pfalz und das saarland stellen den
schulbesuch frei
überall wo es rot ist warnt der deutsche
wetterdienst vor orkanartigen oder sogar
extremen orkanböen im rest des landes
stürmt es zumindest heftig und in
einigen gegenden rüsten sich die
menschen gegen hochwasser los gehen soll
es im norden christoph des torrent
blick von norddeich raus aufs meer
draußen liegen die inseln juist und
norderney ungefähr hier kommt der sturm
zuerst an ab mitternacht soll es
ungemütlich werden weil die windrichtung
dreht und das wasser dann aufs land
gedrückt wird sturmflut gefahr dazu böen
bis stärke 12 da muss man voraus planen
wir haben uns heute im laufe des
vormittags ist entschieden für den
morgigen tag wie auch unsere kollegen
von den anderen aus friesischen inseln
den schiffsverkehr komplett einzustellen
von der küste aus wird es dann immer
heftiger richtung südosten blasen erste
vorboten im erzgebirge autos bleiben
liegen werden eingewählt spätestens in
der zweiten nachthälfte bekommt auch das
flachland die sturmspitzen ab gewarnt
wird vor umknicken den bäumen oder
herumfliegenden dachziegeln das
gefährlich seiner wetterlage sind die
hohen windgeschwindigkeiten vor allem in
der nähe von schauern und gewittern das
kommt dann sehr uns vermittelt mit einem
schlag kommt dann eine orkanartige böen
mit mit 110 kilometern pro stunde oder
orkanböe 120 kilometer bestellung ein
erster windstoß überraschte schon am
nachmittag ein lastwagenfahrer bei
hamburg raus aus seinem waldstück direkt
rein in die höhe und dann in den graben
da half auch die schwere ladung nicht
immerhin der mann blieb unverletzt
die unwetterwarnungen dürften bei
manchen hamburgern erinnerungen wecken
an die schwere sturmflut vor 60 jahren
sie überraschte die menschen im schlaf
mit gedenkfeiern wie in der hamburger
bürgerschaft erinnert die stadt an die
nacht vom 16 auf den 17 februar 1962
damals waren zahlreiche deiche gebrochen
nachdem ein orkan das wasser der nordsee
tage lang in die elbe drückte
340 menschen starben und 20.000 verloren
ihr zuhause
die zerstörungs gewalt von unwettern
zeigt sich gerade auch in brasilien
heftige regenfälle haben in der
bergregion von rio de janeiro zu
erdrutschen und überschwemmungen geführt
mindestens 58 menschen starben
befürchtet werden viel mehr tote denn
noch ist unklar wie viele unter den
schlamm- und wassermassen verschüttet
sind dutzende häuser wurden zerstört und
300 bewohner der stadt petrópolis sind
obdachlos
und jetzt zum riesenerfolg der deutschen
langläuferinnen in die zehnte
goldmedaille für deutschland und
vielleicht sogar die überraschendste
katharina hennig und viktoria kahl
hatten ja schon silber in der staffel
geholt aber mit einem sieg im team
sprint hatte wohl kaum jemand wirklich
gerechnet
katharina heinig und viktoria kahl
gewinne ein unfassbar spannendes rennen
und nach zwölf jahren endlich wieder
gold was uns da heute geknüpft ist oder
was ihr da kämpft haben ist
unbeschreiblich
nach die drei kräftezehrenden 1,5
kilometer runden im wechsel sprintet
ersatzläuferin viktoria kahl auf der
zielgeraden von platz 3 zum sieg und
ich fasse es nicht es wird die
goldmedaille ich habe meinen kopf
komplett ausgeschaltet
als ich auf die zielgerade kam habe ich
nur noch gedacht schief cheep cheep
cheep die nachrückerin hat auch den
bundestrainer völlig umgehauen das ist
tatsächlich sehr traurig muss mittel zum
reisen sonst häufig sehr wieder los
katharina hennig und viktoria kahl
feiern ihren olympiasieg vor den
schwedinnen und russinnen
der und auch die deutschen biathletinnen
hatten heute wieder grund zum jubeln das
dsv quartett mit einzel olympiasiegerin
denise herrmann erkämpfte in der staffel
über 4 x 6 kilometer die bronzemedaille
schlussläuferin denise herrmann völlig
ausgepumpt im ziel sie hatte alles
gegeben für diese staffel medaille
würden wir wirklich so wichtig gestorben
auf beschluss von der seltene art von
darlehen in führung liegend hatte
startläuferin vanessa vogt übergeben an
vanessa hinz die deutschland im
medaillen rennen hielt ebenso wie
franziska preuß deutschland auf rang
vier doch olympiasiegerin denise
herrmann sicherte dem team mit einer
großartigen laufleistung die
bronzemedaille hinter schweden und den
russinnen die erste staffel medaille
seit vancouver 2010
das deutsche ski alpin dagegen hat
weiterhin nichts zu feiern auch linus
strasser verpasste heute eine medaille
der münchner hatte sich nach dem ersten
lauf im slalom als fünfter eigentlich
eine gute ausgangsposition verschafft
fiel dann aber im zweiten lauf zurück
und wurde siebter gold ging an den
franzosen klima
fußball-champions-league die
achtelfinals heute abend treten die
treffen die bayern gegen salz auf
salzburg dieses und andere hinspiele
zusammengefasst bei uns später im
sportstudio ab 23 uhr dort zu sehen auch
die begegnung paris st germain gegen
real madrid von gestern abend mit dem
last minute siegtreffer von psg wilster
mrd zum 100
in der vierten und damit letzten minute
der nachspielzeit spannender geht es
nicht so lud dankeschön ein slot noch
die lottozahlen sie lauten 7 16 29 30 33
43 superzahl 4 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 5 157
nochmal zur erinnerung die warnung vor
orkanartigen böen für höhere lagen im
süden für die mitte und den norden wann
es wo am heftigsten wird erklärt gleich
katja einfach das heute journal gegen
514 mit marietta slomka wir danken für
ihr interesse wünschen ihnen noch einen
schönen abend und alles gute bis morgen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend schon gegen 22 uhr drohen in
ganz deutschland stürmische böen und
sturmböen mit mehr als
62 kilometer pro stunde orkanböen
erwarten wir über der nordsee
orkanartige sturmböen zum beispiel im
harz und schwere sturmböen im
schwarzwald
dieses stromfeld wird uns den ganzen
morgigen tag beschäftigen sie sehen wie
es noch am längsten hier im osten diese
orange farbe gibt der freitag wird
vorübergehend etwas ruhiger aber schon
am freitagnachmittag droht dann das
nächste sturm fällt und das beschäftigt
uns auch noch in der nacht auf samstag
heute nacht gibt es also kräftige
schauer zum teil auch gewitter bei
milden temperaturen von 11 bis 5 grad
bäume werden umstürzen und sie sollten
sich unbedingt von wäldern fern halten
auch morgen geht es weiter mit diesen
kräftigen schauern bei milden
temperaturen
guten abend